it comes like this it plugs into your
own television so out of the back here
we've got a cable that's just connecting
into a standard aerial input in fact it
was quite a job trying to find a TV that
would plug into this computer so George
a few minutes ago just did a race up to
the other end of the physics building to
try and find a monitor sufficiently old
which would plug into this computer the
home computer that I got out my parents
lost actually I think my dad bought it
in about I use probably defender in 1982
I think my dad used it most to start
with and then quite rapidly I got it I
was worried about 11 years old at the
time and I basically taught myself to
program using this this thing here which
this is the BBC micro this is a BBC
model B microcomputer it was one of the
earliest computers one of the earliest
home computers and it was actually made
for the BBC so this was a time when
computers were completely brand new so
nobody nobody had seen computers
computers weren't these all ubiquitous
things that you have in homes and
offices now so people didn't really
understand them and so the BBC wanted to
develop a project to get to introduce
people to computers and and programming
because this was going to be the next
big thing and the BBC thought this was
going to be the next big thing so they a
commission that can accompany a British
company called acorn to make this
computer not only badged it with the BBC
badge and the BBC did a series of TV
programs using this computer to try and
teach people how to program a lot of
people you find they're working
professionally in computer computers now
computer programming certainly in my age
their first experience of computer
programming and computers will be
something something like this or as that
X spectrum or a Commodore 64 or
something like that it's getting on a
bit now this computer and so it tends to
overheat after a while so I've just
taken the screws off so we can actually
take the top off this is the central
processing unit here so this is a 6502
central processing unit and that process
is running at two megahertz so you can
pair that with a clock speed of modern
computer
which is around about two to four
gigahertz so we're running this is
running about a thousand times slower
than the typical computer nowadays it's
got 32 K of memory that's 32 thousand
bytes of memory this is the memory down
here this is the area down here is the
memory and all these chips amount to 32
kilobytes so it's 32 times 1,024 bytes
of memory so you can pair that with a
modern computer which has now got
something of the reason of a gigabytes
of memory so you can see how much of a
difference there is between the modern
PC and these keys types of computers but
one of the really neat things about this
is that it turns on instantaneously so
you don't have to wait for it to boot up
so if I do this and turn it off and turn
it on and that's it it's ready to go you
just turn it on it's ready to go and the
reason is because if I just move this
keyboard here so it's because that the
software the operating system of the
computer is stored on ROM which is a
read-only memory as a chip so you don't
it's got no hard disk inside it's got no
disk drive attached to it at all in fact
all the software that it needs to run is
stored on this chip so when you when you
switch it on it's ready to go and that
means I always put the cover back on
again and that means we can start
programming it straight away we can make
it do stuff really straight away and as
you can see once when you turn it on
you're presented with this it says here
the BBC computer 32k that tells us how
much memory we've got to play with basic
so we've launched into the basic
programming language so we're not
presented with any mice pointers windows
or anything like that just a cursor and
we can start just immediately writing a
computer program so I can stop enter
line 10 and let's try writing the
simplest ever program ever written first
and remember how to do this
I'm going to use the dreaded go-to okay
so that's a that's the first program
that pretty much anybody have a right so
when you learn to start programming
there you go so you just print hello
world millions of times over until you
tell it to stop press escape and I can
list that program back by tackling list
and you say it basically start you start
off with line ten says print hello world
and the second line just tells it to go
back to line ten again I started just
mucking about with the graphics so this
is you know you can write programs to do
you know muck around with playing with
text and things but I wanted to start
playing with graphics so I can write a
little program to let's let's start
another one remember the command to do
it this is going back a few years now
I'm going to tell it to repeat this
program I'm going to choose a color
random color each time this computer's
got one of seven colors or eight if you
include black so that's how many colors
you want to play with then I'm going to
just tell it to plot triangles
everywhere and last thing I need to do
is change it to a graphics mode so if I
type run now I should just print
triangle so every place so various
different colors so it's not much to
look at but the beauty of it is you can
really just you can get into programming
so easily doing this and you can you can
start doing more fancy things like
plotting circles and the at ado figures
and things like that and then you can
make it do sounds by typing just one
command at the command line like this so
so you muck around with planes stop that
say muck around with sounds and graphics
and that's what I got into as a kid and
I spent ages and ages but probably far
too long learning how to program out of
this this user guide at one point it had
a ring binder on it and I just spent my
time reading this this was my bedtime
reading when I was a kid is a bit sad
really I suppose but that's what that's
what I wanted to do and that's the so
like holding that book again if it was
big part of your childhood um it's quite
unusual oh it's quite unusual I actually
kept it some of the pages that still are
turned upside down for some reason
but yeah I couldn't bear to throw it
away really I mean I've got a lot of
computers have had since and I've just
when they've come to the end of the life
I've just thrown them away and they're
just expendable but this one because
it's the first one I ever had
I just gotta sticks to my fingers and I
try to throw it away I can't get rid of
it and I'm sure a lot of people but we
feel the same thing the same way
actually so they'll have a piece of
technology a first bit of technology
like this which they just can't bear to
throw away
so this is this is a computer game
called elite elite was the first really
proper game to use three-dimensional
graphics okay like so it's firing at us
now sadly I can still name that
spaceship which is a copper mark 3 as we
got some pirate something